either reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
today an Indian movie trailer golly boy
based on the true story of Greg Alba I'm
excited to check this out my brother
Jabby Kawai recommended me this if
you're Indian subscriber odds are you
found me on his channel so I'm happier
here and he said we should definitely do
this we have a trailer here that has
English subtitles on it big thanks to
excuse me if I say this wrong Rashi he
specifically told me how not to say it
and I feel like that's the way I'm
remembering of how to say it but how
come I go against your instincts would
Hulk are close yeah thanks Rashi let's
watch this we don't really watch a lot
of Indian trailers so this should be fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what opportunity one shot hip-hop game
I carry doesn't look like a rapper he's
gonna do it you might just make it this
rap game
[Music]
it's hard
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn that's hard how bad this hardcore
yeah man that's hardcore
it looks like really gritty you know rap
game come up Indian Mile yeah man yeah
talk about the relevance the the dirty
money out there rule in the country
keeping people down I'd be very curious
to actually check this movie yeah
because you know when we get a lot of
movies about rappers in the States it's
usually a similar type of trajectory
similar type of plot beats making it
against the audience you're poor you
struggle you're supposed to go down a
different type of traditional cliche
path I can imagine though that and I
don't know much about Indian culture I
should be more well-versed I should ask
my brother a couple the questions cuz he
knows more than I do that's my exact
point of why be curious to check this
out because even though it's gonna
follow a similar beat structure of a guy
who you shouldn't be rapping what are
you doing what are you have the
expectation that you'll follow your
family's footsteps yeah I feel like this
could have a lot of cool like cultural
references infuse through I feel like
culture will play a big part into this
path that he's going down more so than
it would play out here you know and in a
movie like I could be American culture
it's not really yeah it's like usually
if it's a rapper it's like about being a
in American movies know being a poor
black guy here and it plays a lot to
like black culture out in the States
this is something totally different and
I feel like that's where a lot of the
uniqueness the unique experience would
come from because it's a cool scene this
guy who is actor I'm not familiar with
you know he just looks like a regular
working guy yes opposed to oh damn he's
an Indian rapper yeah it looks like just
a regular dude who's going into this and
like some of my favorite moments here
are the moments or who's trying to rap
in privacy like when he's in the
passenger seat of his car and he's
trying to like rap a lot to fit into the
the mannerisms cashews of it all yeah
like that I can identify with I have
this obsession where if I really love a
rap song I'm gonna try to just memorize
all the lyrics I'm not pursuing a rap
career
I'm not doing anything like that but
what I really love a rap song I try to
really get hold of those lyrics down and
it can be so embarrassing or silly what
I'm doing it in front of other people so
a lot I'm like I'm in my car like to
remember it seeing that my really cook
with that right there is a guy who
fantasizes about the idea of wrapping
this really clicked with me in that
department - oh yeah definitely well and
a non cultural level - I mean so much of
Rapa mean you know you obviously have
the glitz and the glamor and that kind
of thing but a big part of the DNA of
the art form is speaking truth to power
and and shining light on you know the
pockets of society that are being kind
of mistreated and mishandled and I'm
curious to see what this movie does with
that because it is a different culture
and ours and there are different issues
at play in India and whatnot and also -
from you know a cinema who is very rich
with musical history and musical
vibrance I'm curious to see how rap
figures into that because I've never
seen a Bollywood movie or an Indian
movie with a rap you know bent to it you
know I've seen other musical movies and
stuff like that movies where music plays
a big part and it has that sort of
realistic sort of grungy style it feels
very alien life you know and it's cool
really long with the subtitles because
the sub not really rhyming that's always
the thing is I always these and watching
like the kpop music videos we've seen
and stuff like that always make me wish
I understood the languages intimately
cuz you know that there's just so much
that doesn't quite translate so yeah
inevitably I'm gonna miss certain things
that make these raps what they are sure
you know and general I really like rap
movies because of how rap is just such a
straightforward hard version of poetry
the bottom use where you get to really
express yourself your anger your angst
whatever emotions you're actually
feeling you just really let it all out
when you're actually rapping when
they're doing the music parts it's so
it's always so resembling and so
clear-cut
the characters what they're saying that
can be more appealing to me than a
musical because then a typical musical
because of the fact that these lyrics
are so in tune with who the characters
are that you're probably gonna watch
experiences that truly reflect almost
each and every line that they're talking
about
I love the angle - of how you have these
specific relationships this main
character has his relationship with his
father and a relationship with it was
his girlfriend yeah I think it's his
girlfriends I got yeah and it seems like
they got like a cool love story and a
really good supporting love story here
and then you got the dad does not want
this for him whatsoever yeah I catch you
doing them raps again I'm gonna rap you
on the head so if there's a lot to
identify with here I give what my
brother wanted me to check this out
because this is the kind of movie I
would definitely watch in a heartbeat
this might be the only Indian movie
review yeah personally I'm just excited
to like come into the apartment and find
you rehearsing these from the computer
looking at the translations you know
off-book and all that stuff's gonna be
great we're really excited for it hey
before we wrap this up I want to give a
page from the day shout-out to a man
named JM Valente I say - JM Valente that
you have a good day on break you're a
cool guy I Love You Man I cook eggs in a
frying pan you are like a big fan of us
you're kind of like our Stan and let's
see how many rhymes I could cram into
this little time spam that we have to do
this shout out what am I really talking
about I was never a part of the Boy
Scouts but John was I was I was a wee
below yo looking at back in the day
people used to call me fat gay but I
overcame and I'm still very insecure -
you overcame but dude there's no reason
to have any sense of shame because you
were the furthest thing from being lame
you got those emotions tamed no but I
said it like a what I know
really aggressive vote of confidence
it's great that J it actually had to get
surgery recently on his eyeball ooh
which one his Center will open up
spiritually the possibilities so I hope
you're feeling better J and you've been
part of our patreon page for such a long
time that you have definitely earned
these rhymes anyhoo subscribe the real
rejects like that notification now check
us on patreon we got a lot of stuff we
don't act real tough life can be a
little bit rough and I lost a lot of
weight last year and this time I'm gonna
get buff